I had a guy come at me on social media
he's like we'll all women are just liars
like oh okay
let's say some of these women are liars
just for a thought experiment you have
to admit the reaction of men lying and
women lying in our culture is very
different you've seen the movie catch me
if you can great movie it's about a con
artist he pretends to be a doctor
pretends to be a pilot so if you're a
woman and you lie you're a monster if
you're a man and you lie you get a movie
made about you starring Leonardo
DiCaprio what do we get we got fucking
hi Tania that's what we got you have to
be in a leotard for anyone to give a
shit I also did research on the guy that
that movie is based on he now works at
the FBI they pay him millions of dollars
to consult on other con artists so if
you're a man and you lie that's like a
hireable skill okay people don't like
when women lie they get very
uncomfortable when women lie that's my
theory about why there's no female
magicians never thought about that shit
before because when men lie we're like
wow
if there was a female magician after
every trick everyone in the audience
would be like I fuckin knew it when I
tell you I told you cannot trust these
bitches bitches the other generalization
I keep hearing is well all these women
are just gold diggers like okay fine
let's say let's even say some of these
women are gold diggers you guys have to
admit that you guys were afraid of gold
diggers way before this even happened
it's hard for us to hear you guys
complain about gold diggers because when
you guys complain about gold diggers to
us it kind of just sounds like you're
bragging we're like well a lot of ways
you have all that gold is because you
have the advantage of being a guy
especially if you're in the goods and
services industry a lot of reason you
have all that money it's cuz we buy a
bunch of shit we don't fucking need so
if I'm dating the head of Sephora and I
gold dig him I'm not using him for his
money
I'm using it for my money that is my
money I'm just trying to get that shit
back I feel like you go take me first
bronzer should not be $90 when guys can
play about gold diggers it's tricky
because to us the solution is so obvious
it's like if you're worried about gold
diggers I have an idea how about just
date women with their own fucking gold I
don't know maybe stop dating eighteen
year olds that need a Kickstarter
campaign
the state adults with jobs